OTTAWA, BUT THEY'VE WON
THREE OF THEIR LAST 13 HOME
GAMESES A SAVE ON THAT.
GREAT PACE SHIELDS OFF BRYSON A
POWER PLAY.
DELL THE SAVE AND THE PUCK SENE
GAMBRELL.
PAUL TRYING TO CENTRE IT.
JOKIHARJU S
BREAKAWAY HERE.
NO, I DON'T, JANKOWSKI TAKES IT
FROM ME.
EVERYONE T T WITH TAGE THOMPSON
THE LAST FOUR GAMES IN
GOOD NEWS THERE
>> Mike: GREAT NEWS FOR HIM AND
THE  GOOD
GROUP
>> Go
THE HE WAS TRYING TO FIND
TKACHUK AT THE BACK DOOR.
>> Gord:
GOOD SAVE BY MATTHEW THACHUK.
NOW YOU GET A AO CENTER ICE.
HERE'S GAUDETTE WITH IT. HE GETT
YOU DID. DAHLIN LOOKING ON. ARO
BUT TKACHUK WITH A STEAL,
OFFEE
HAVE CAUGHT UP TO HIS OF THOSE
>> Gord: NUMBER SOMEONE HASN'T
REINS ALTHOUGH SKINNER
BROUGHT IN,N, THERE WERE.
REALLY LONG TIM
HAVEN'T WON A PLAYOFF SERIES
SINCE  FOR BUFFALO
EEN AROUND
AND BACK.  IS APULL
IT OFF
>> Gord: BR MINUS 37 LOOK OUT F
KEEP IT.
>> Mike: THAT'S GREAT STUFF.